[Musique]
êtes-vous réellement satisfait de la façon dont votre
vie s'est déroulée, quoi d'autre ne sera pas que
savez-vous de ce rappel, s'il vous plaît,
restez à l'écart de maintenant presque avec
Jemima,
bienvenue pour vous recommander pour la première fois comment s'est passé votre
fantasme vous donnera le souvenir que vous
souhaitez  sois le combattant du crime ou
l'athlète de classe mondiale notre agent secret
ouais, les
sentiers heureux, mec, qu'est-ce que c'est, qu'est-ce qui ne va pas ouais,
j'ai besoin de beaucoup avant que cela ne se produise, quelle erreur,
personne
Oh,
essaies-tu de me tuer, ta mémoire
a été effacée, ton esprit a été implanté avec
une vie sur laquelle je pense que tu as vécu d'autant plus que
tu n'as même pas commencé à me voir
essayer de te tuer alors ne te laisse pas te
voir partout
je ne suis pas moi alors qui diable suis-je tu
n'as pas  le souvenir le plus fiable,
n'est-ce pas ?